In 1992, seven of the hottest artists in comics
left Marvel to form Image Comics, and before
long, one of those artists had a hit on their
hands.
Todd McFarlane’s Spawn quickly became a
phenomenon.
The story of a black ops soldier killed in
action and resurrected as a supernatural warrior
meant to serve the will of Hell, Spawn has
turned into a media empire, with almost 300
issues of his own comic, numerous spin-offs,
video games, an HBO animated series, a live-action
movie, and more.
"Welcome to my world!
From Todd McFarlane's Spawn, She-Spawn!"
From the fairly public legal battles to the
character’s surprising secret origin, here
are the stories about Spawn that you won’t
find on the comic page.
Sweet Sixteen
When Image launched with all-new characters,
McFarlane didn't have to think long to figure
out what he wanted to do.
He’d been waiting since 1977 to tell the
story of Spawn, a character he created when
he was 16 years old, and the dawn of Image
Comics gave him the opportunity to bring him
to life… or undeath, depending on how you
look at it.
To back up his claims of creating Spawn as
a teenager, McFarlane took to Facebook in
October of 2017 to post what he said was one
of his first drawings of the character.
He’s not quite the version we know today,
with a different color scheme and what appears
to be a cartoony sidekick, but it’s clearly
a prototype version of Al Simmons’ hell-spawned
alter-ego.
The big difference?
McFarlane said he originally envisioned Spawn
as being from space rather than the underworld.
"I dub three SPAWN!
General of hell's army!"
So many powers
If you don't know much about Spawn, your first
instinct might be to ask, "What powers does
he have?"
It’s a simple question, and even for an
infamously powerful character like Superman,
you can rattle off a list of all of his major
abilities pretty quickly.
With Spawn, however, we could be here all
day.
He's got the standard-issue enhanced strength
and durability that you’d expect from a
superhero, but that’s barely scratching
the surface.
As of Spawn #4, he was blasting glowing “necroplasm”
out of his hands, and surviving the violent
loss of limbs and major organs.
In later stories, he’s seen teleporting,
resurrecting the dead, breathing fire, stopping
time, animating chains, and plenty of other
wild displays of power.
It’s enough to make you wonder if he could
ever be threatened enough to keep readers
interested, but with the comic still going
strong after 25 years, it doesn't seem his
Swiss Army knife collection of powers has
hurt his appeal.
A landmark in diversity
Before his death and resurrection, Spawn was
Al Simmons, a black man.
You wouldn’t know that from looking at his
full-body costume, or even the rotted corpse
underneath, but that’s also on purpose.
McFarlane has said on numerous occasions that
his choice to make Simmons African-American
was in part because of a story he never got
to tell while he was working on Spider-Man.
The hypothetical scene would have Spider-Man
save a white man from a black criminal, only
to have the man he saved use a racial slur
to describe the crook.
“Because he's covered from head to toe,
unlike Batman, he's covered from head to toe,
and go, 'what color do you think I am under
this mask?'"
The 1997 Spawn movie may not have been met
with critical acclaim for obvious reasons…
"Easy with that face, I'm eating.
Opps, a wet one."
...or even record-breaking ticket sales, but
McFarlane’s choice did lead to a landmark
for superhero movies: Michael Jai White wound
up being the first African-American actor
to play a major comic book superhero, though
just barely: Spawn's theatrical release preceded
the release of Steel, starring Shaquille O'Neal,
by only 14 days.
"With a will of iron, a heart of gold, and
a body of steel…"
"It's hammer time."
Spawn goes digital
By leaving Marvel at the height of his popularity,
co-founding a successful independent publisher,
and using a single character’s success to
launch a cross-media empire, it’s easy to
argue Todd McFarlane spent a lot of time on
the bleeding edge of the comics industry.
That’s why it's so surprising that when
it came to digital publishing, he was one
of the last creators to get on board.
McFarlane told the Washington Post that holding
off from digital publishing was his way of
staying loyal to brick-and-mortar comic book
shops by keeping Spawn on the shelves and
off the tablets.
Eventually, though, the convenience of digital
won out.
At the release of Spawn #250 in 2015, the
entire library became available online.
The unreleased crossover
With his overwhelming popularity in the ‘90s,
it’s not surprising that Spawn starred in
plenty of crossovers, including two notable
stories where he teamed up with Batman.
The first was drawn by McFarlane with a script
by Dark Knight Returns creator Frank Miller,
which actually left literal scars on Spawn
that carried over to his own comic.
The second was Batman/Spawn: War Devil, and
in 2015, McFarlane revealed that there were
originally plans to complete a Batman/Spawn
trilogy that never came to pass.
McFarlane signed on to write and ink while
artist Greg Capullo, who got his start on
Spawn before moving to an epic five-year run
on Batman, would have drawn.
McFarlane didn't say precisely why the crossover
died on the vine, only that it was for a variety
of reasons which he claimed most of the responsibility
for.
The war over Angela
During the first year of Spawn, McFarlane
invited a number of well-known comic book
writers to write issues of the series, including
notable writer Neil Gaiman.
In Spawn #9, Gaiman introduced an angelic
warrior named Angela and the Medieval Spawn,
who would wind up being very important as
Spawn’s saga went on.
Gaiman felt he deserved more compensation
for his contributions, and after a failed
negotiation involving the rights to another
character, Gaiman filed suit against McFarlane
in 2002.
Ten years later, the two creators finally
settled.
The details weren’t released to the public,
but Gaiman was granted ownership of Angela.
In 2013, in a move that surprised many readers,
he brought her into the Marvel Universe, where
she was eventually revealed to be Thor’s
sister.
McFarlane's diplomatic response to the news
was that "Whatever Neil chooses to do with
something that he owns is at his complete
and utter discretion."
Taking back the reins
Over 20 years after his first film, Spawn
is returning to the big screen in a live-action
reboot scheduled for production in 2018, and
this time, McFarlane will be writing and directing.
He’s made it clear he doesn't intend for
it to be anything like the 1997 movie, and
even claims that it won’t be a superhero
film either.
Instead, he frequently compares it to Steven
Spielberg’s Jaws, with Spawn in the role
of the shark.
The story will be told through the eyes of
the normal people around him, and will skip
over the origin story completely.
As McFarlane says, "Did they tell me why the
shark was so damn big?
No!
Did it matter to me?
No!”
Will it be as ridiculous as the first?
"Noooo!"
"Oh come on, you scream like a girl!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!